You're here
now.
How do I know that I'm actually live?
Hey guys.
Can you hear me?
Hi everyone.
Good to see you.
So I'm a little tired side tonight.
So I'm going to start with a relatively
straightforward question.
Somebody asked what's up with all the
Lenin pictures in your house and then
how is it to look at them every day?
Well,
about
in 2001 in a fit of collective insanity.
I decided to start seeing if I could
find Soviet era artifacts online.
Mostly through Ebay.
I had read a paper by James Pennebaker
who claimed the past events start to
become historically significant about 15
years after the after the relevant event
and so 2001 was 15 years after the
fault,
essentially after the fall of the Berlin
Wall or close enough.
And so I started looking on Ebay to see
what sort of Soviet artifacts or might
be able to find.
First of all,
I was kind of curious about what would
be available for purchase and I also
thought it was deeply ironic that the
most free market of,
of what would you call platforms ever
devised,
which would be Ebay could now be used to
scavenge communist era artists,
Alex from Russia,
you know,
it just seemed like to be someone who
was during the Cold War,
the fact that,
that,
that I could buy things like heads of
linen on Ebay was just too comical to
not to pass up,
you know.
And so I started buying things that I
had some familiarity with because of
what I'd read historically.
And the first thing I bought was about a
three by five silk flag that was awarded
to a factory for meeting its five year
production quota.
And I don't know what you know about
those infamous quotas,
but what would happen is that there were
addictive sent down on high about how
much factories were supposed to produce
and the implied,
um,
what the implication was produced or
else by any means necessary.
And so two things happened.
Three things happened.
The goods were often shawty because they
were rushed,
there was deception about how much was
actually produced and then people were
radically overworked and under supplied,
so it was a bad bad system,
but it was very interesting to actually
have one of these flags and see what
they were like and then I bought a
clock,
a stainless steel clock,
windup clock that was a submarine clock
and it was bomb proof,
so I thought that would be handy if
someone ever bombed my house and I
needed to know what time it was.
So I bought that and then I found this
painting that's actually off to my left
here.
It's five Russian revolutionaries,
all young and quite stalwart looking,
standing on the edge of a cliff with a
red soldier or a white soldier off to
the side.
They're all shackled together and he's
preparing to execute them.
That was a.
That was a fairly common Soviet motif
and I'm on my right side.
I have a and a decorated Soviet war hero
who's working in a steel foundry and
like a lot of the Soviet or glorified I
suppose the working class.
And I suppose there's nothing wrong with
that,
depending on the degree of
propagandistic content and
falsifications,
but
they're kind of like Norman Rockwell
paintings,
except they don't have the same degree
of sentimentality,
which is quite interesting.
And what's it like to have them around?
Well,
pretty much every square inch of my
house is covered with paintings and a
fair number of them are,
I don't suppose the sorts of paintings
that people would usually have in their
house.
There was,
some of them are of the Second World
War.
Some of them are strongly political and
uh,
but it's,
it's.
Well sometimes people say,
well,
I wouldn't want to live in a museum.
And I guess that isn't how I feel.
I actually like living in the museum.
And I liked having these historical
artifacts,
so around and I really liked watching
the propaganda and the art more in the,
in the paintings,
because many of these paintings were
produced by very talented impressionist
artists who were trained.
The classical European tradition.
They spent months making these paintings
and yet their subordinate in some sense
to a political ideology.
But what's interesting is that as the
political ideology recedes into the
past,
the more purely artistic elements of the
paintings seem to remain.
And so it's cool to kind of watch it's
very slow process.
But it's very interesting to watch the
art itself emerged triumphant over the
propaganda and then,
you know,
these things also reminded me of,
of what,
what I'm interested in and that's the
study of videology and they reminded me
how powerful ideology can be and how
many different pathways that can take
two to,
to control I suppose it.
And,
and it also reminds me of the reality of
the 20th century because it was a
terrible reality.
And if we forget it then we weren't
likely to repeat it.
Now my kids grew up in this house and I
asked them about it because I suppose
the paintings are fairly heavy and maybe
even somewhat frightening,
but they really liked it and the people
that I.
It gives me a reason to invite people
into my house and gives me something to
play with.
And,
and I,
I guess I need things to play with by
all appearances.
So that's the story of the,
of the Soviet paintings.
So
please tell us about your ideas of the
problem of gender integrated combat
units and how it affects morale.
Please talk about the role trans people
should or should not serve in combat
units.
Huh?
Well,
you know,
I wouldn't say that I'm
exactly an expert in that regard.
Um,
I don't know how gender
power,
multiple gender combat units are going
to work my because I'm fundamentally a
traditionalist in most ways.
Mostly because I'm afraid of the
unintended consequences of radical
change.
I would say that it's dangerous to
adjust a system that's working and it's
very hard for me to imagine a situation,
especially in a combat situation where
the women and men can actually be
treated equally.
I don't think that the broader society
would even want to see that.
I mean I suppose there are exceptions to
that sort of thing.
Like,
like,
um,
the situation perhaps in Israel,
although I suspect even in Israel that
the women take the more,
the less combat heavy jobs now I don't
know that but,
and maybe I'm just being prejudiced in
that answer,
but
it just doesn't seem to me to be a very
wise idea.
Um,
what role trans people should serve.
I really can't say I,
I don't have anything,
any advice about that.
I'm just not
informed enough to make
a conclusion about that.
I think it's very strange.
However,
I've talked to some people in the
Canadian armed forces in recent months
and I do think it's very strange that
this is the sort of problem that our
military is actually trying to solve
you.
You'd think that there would be more
important things to concentrate on then
rapid gender,
um,
equalization in the military.
I just don't see why that's such a
priority,
but maybe that's just my old fashioned
conservatism speaking it.
It could be,
it could be that I'm derek fake asks,
how do you see love arrows in your
general world view?
Where does love come from?
You guys?
Yeah.
Asking possibly hard questions.
Well,
I think that truth has to be embodied
inside love or in embedded inside love.
You know,
it's not easy to figure out a hierarchy
of values,
of ultimate values.
There's great.
The great traditional values of the good
and the beautiful and the true,
let's say,
to courageous and that sort of thing.
It's not easy to figure out how you
arrange those hierarchically,
but it seems to me that truth is likely
something that serves a master of one
form or another at least ethical truth
and love is something like the decision
that being is fundamentally good or it's
the decision to act as if being as
fundamentally good.
That might be the right way of thinking
about it.
So
I thought about this in relationship to
my son when he was little,
three years old and like unbearably cute
and you know,
little three year olds,
they're,
they're fairly easily hurt.
I mean,
they're quite robust in some ways,
but they're fairly easily hurt.
They can run out into traffic and you
know,
they skinned their knees and they bang
heads on table sued,
you know,
they're prone to emotional breakdown and
they have all these extreme fragilities
that make you nervous,
I would say,
and alert and attended as an adult.
But that also expose you directly to
the,
to the fact of the potential tragedy of
life coaches.
I think one of the reasons why having
children matures you in a way that
nothing else can.
And you know,
I imagined,
I've written about this in my new book,
12 rules for life.
I imagined that I could remove his
vulnerabilities one by one so that he
couldn't be hurt.
So,
you know,
I thought,
well I could make them into a robot and
it was 15 feet tall and made out of
metal and that would remove his physical
vulnerability,
can have tremendous strength and you
know,
you could turn them into something like
a superhero with all these,
with all these strengths instead of
these exceptional vulnerabilities.
But what I realized very rapidly was
that every time he removed a
vulnerability,
you removed an essential part of the
person.
Right,
a part that you really love because with
that little three year old boy kid for
example mean it's there,
it's there,
it's there.
Fragility in some sense that's a huge
part of their charm and appeal.
It's not like you'd wish it on them,
but it's part of their.
It's part of their value as beings and I
think that reflects something like the
paradoxical situation that the Dallas
referred to when when they in the Tao Te
Ching and they talk about the what makes
a plot valuable is the empty space
inside it.
It's,
it's what it's not as much as what it is
that makes it well actual first of all
real but also useful and there's
something really profound about that in
that limitations.
So I would say limitation is the
precondition for being.
And it's really I,
I'd like to get this right so that you
can follow it because it's,
it's one of the most useful thoughts I
think that has ever occurred to me.
The first is the
limits are a precondition for being.
Just like rules are preconditioned for a
game.
Like you can't play a game where you can
make any move at any time.
You have to narrow the playing field
substantially and you have to put
restrictions on what can be done in
order for anything to be done and so
maybe being is this paradoxical state
where there's there's just enough
limitation to maximize possibility,
something like that and that seems right
to me why that would be.
I have no idea,
but maybe that's something like an
answer to why,
why there's anything,
why anything was created or I know I'm
speaking metaphysically but but I still
think it's worthwhile doing so and then
well,
if,
if limitation is the precondition for
being then then that that introduces
suffering into the world and tragedy
because of course suffering and tragedy
or consequence of limitation and so then
the situation is that if you want to
have the being where possibility is
maximized,
you have to accept the limitations that
produced tragedy and so that's maybe the
justification for tragedy.
Assuming that such a thing needs to be
justified.
And then the final thought in that three
part series as well.
Maybe there's a way to live so that the
tragedy that's an intrinsic part of
limited being becomes bearable or
becomes even something like celebrate
and I guess that would be akin to
Nietzsche's wish for the eternal return
like he thought you should live so that
if every moment that you lived recurred
eternally that that would be a good
thing,
and so it's a heroic motive being.
It's conceivable that are heroic mode of
being that requires the adoption of
responsibility,
gives your life sufficient gravitas and
weight and meaning so that the tragedy
of being can be withstood without
becoming corrupt,
and I would certainly hope that that
would be the case.
And I think there's some reasons to
assume that it might be.
So.
Can you talk more about the
resurrection?
This remains a stumbling block for many
of your more atheistic followers who
have otherwise embraced your approach to
understanding Christianity.
Well.
I can only talk about it symbolically to
begin with and that's,
I think,
not sufficient,
but I hope as I moved through the
Biblical series that I can zero in on
that more and more particularly,
but
the idea of the dying and resurrected
God is a very old idea.
Um,
and it's echoed in such things as the
imagery save the Phoenix which burns
itself up.
And then Ms Dot Torres itself to its,
to its early form.
And I think speaking purely
psychologically,
that idea of the dying and resurrected
savior is something like a reflection of
the fact that in order to progress
psychologically,
you have to let go.
Especially in the face of obstacles.
You have to let go of those things that
are impeding your progress that might be
very dear to your heart.
You have to let them go and let them
die.
And then you have to let a new part of
yourself be born.
So because when you're wrong,
you have to let the part of you that's
wrong,
die.
And then a new part spring to life.
In some sense.
It's a new part that's partly a union of
your mind and union of the information
that's contained in the error that you
committed and it's like the birth in
some sense of the new spirit and so you
could say that there's this idea that
you have to have faith in Christ because
Christ is the way and the truth and the
life.
No one comes to the father but through,
but through him.
What that means symbolically as far as I
can tell that is that you have to
embrace the process of voluntary death
and rebirth in order to continue moving
forward properly in your life and it.
It's also that process of death and
rebirth that rejuvenates the father and
it's also that process of death and
rebirth that produces the father to
begin with.
If you think about the father is the
symbol of of culture,
so at minimum the idea of the
resurrected Christ is the idea that you
should identify not with that part of
yourself that stagnant and dead and that
already knows but is prone to error.
You should identify with that part of
yourself that's always stretching beyond
what you currently know and has the
faith to let go of old certainties so
that new patterns of being can be
brought into place.
And so now that's a purely psychological
explanation and I think I made the case
in my biblical lectures that I'm
striving for a psychological
interpretation at the moment.
Um,
my experience with the biblical stories
is that there are layers of depth in
them that are sufficiently profound
perhaps because of the staggering
hyperlinking of the text and its
association with almost the entire
Corpus of Western literature that as you
keep digging,
you find more and more.
And so,
um,
I don't know what to make of the more
metaphysical claims,
you know,
and,
but I'm going to leave it at that
because I don't know,
it's only speculation.
Um,
see,
I guess it is that we don't,
I really don't believe that we
understand consciousness and we don't
understand its role in the cosmos.
It could be that consciousness is just
an epiphenomenon of materialist
processes,
but there's a couple of things to me
that seems to mitigate against that
explanation,
and the first is that we don't have an
account of consciousness that's that's
useful.
We have no idea how the material
substrate of the brain produces this.
This awareness and self awareness that
seems to be crucially important in the
existence of the cosmos and so far as if
there's nothing to experience,
something.
It's very difficult to say in what way
that it exists.
You need a viewer and an observer and
scientists sort of gerrymandered out by
positing a hypothetical observer when
they talk about a phenomena where there
is no actual observer and so
consciousness could be just an EPA
phenomena,
but it could also be something central
to the nature of being and certainly
mythological stories presented that way
that there's.
There's nature now.
It would be nurtured from a scientific
perspective and there's the social world
that would be the great father from the
mythological perspective and and that's
all there is from a scientific
perspective,
but from a mythological perspective,
there's active consciousness and that's
associated with the idea of the logos
and the logos seems to be something like
if you think about it as consciousness,
it seems to be this thing that
encounters the potential of future being
and then determines at least in part how
to shape it.
Obviously we're constrained in many
ways.
We can't shape things in any old way,
but we can certainly advance in the
direction of our imagination and quite
staggering and compelling manner.
And then you might say,
is that real?
Is is is the idea that we have a
consciousness and that it's free in some
in in incomprehensible sense,
and that it plays a role in constructing
the cosmos?
Is that real?
And then I would say,
well,
it depends on what you mean by real,
but I would also point out that you act
as if it's real and that are functional.
Legal systems like the legal systems of
on the West are predicated on the
acceptance of its reality.
And it was an idea that took many,
many thousands of years to be merge
know.
First of all,
the only sovereign was well was the king
and God.
And then the nobles became sovereign and
then men became sovereign.
And then with the Christian revolution,
every individual's soul became
sovereign.
That idea of of individual sovereignty
and worth is the core presupposition of
our legal system and our cultural
systems.
And so we all walk around acting as if
every one of us is a divine center of
logos because we give each other the
respect of,
of,
of individual citizens who are sovereign
and that are equal before the law.
And the funny thing is is if someone
doesn't treat you that way,
he treats you as if you're free.
Will is an illusion or refuses to regard
you as someone who plays a active part
in choosing outcome of their life.
Then you get very,
very annoyed.
And so if it's an illusion and perhaps
it is,
we don't understand an alternative to it
and it's unbelievably,
it's unbelievably functional.
So okay,
so back to love.
Well,
um,
will make the case that a limitation is
necessary for being.
And then we can make the case that
tragedy is an inevitable consequence of
limitation.
And then we might say,
well,
is being worth the tragedy.
And I think the answer yes to that is
love.
And the answer no to that is the
opposite of love because when you,
when you love someone,
you love them in spite of or even
because of their vulnerability,
not that you don't want them to
transcend that because you do.
But,
and I think that love is the acceptance
of the price of being.
It's the way you manifest your
acceptance of the price of being.
Because if you love someone,
you know,
they have their vulnerabilities like
every human being,
but your basic judgment is that despite
the fact that they have these
vulnerabilities that are even fatal and
that are certainly tragic,
that it's better that they were then
that they weren't,
and that's,
and I think that's the right attitude to
have towards being itself.
Uh,
it's,
it's an optimistic attitude
and I think it has to be predicated on
faith because I don't think that you can
necessarily derive that conclusion by,
by looking at the available evidence.
The evidence is kind of 50 slash 50 and
in many situations,
but,
but I can tell you if you adopt the
other attitude that being is
unjustifiable,
then that leads you down a very,
very dark road and then you assume start
to work in a way that makes things far
more intolerable then they should be.
So that's,
um,
that's my answer to that.
Any tips on avoiding booze?
Yeah,
that's a real tough one.
Well,
I would say a couple of things.
There is a drug.
If you're a binge drinker,
there is a drug called naltrexone that
you could consider and you take mail
trucks on every day.
It doesn't really have any psychological
effect on you,
but if you're a naltrexone responder,
what'll happen is that it will dampen
your positive response to alcohol.
So some people who are alcoholic,
many of them have a very pronounced
opiate,
is a,
uh,
an opiate effect from alcohol.
It looks like it's mediated by Beta
endorphin and now trick zone into is an
opiate blocker.
And so,
um,
what naltrexone seems to do is dampen
the positive response and the positive
response,
which would be opiate.
And then dopaminergic is the same
response that makes you want to keep
drinking when you start drinking.
So if you're one of those people that
has a drink and then has to have another
one and then has to have another one and
you know,
soon all your money's gone,
then the probability that you have an
opiate response is pretty high.
And now trick someone can help with
that.
Um,
generally when people take naltrexone
and they keep drinking,
they try to control,
but they keep drinking.
And they learn over time that the
alcohol doesn't have the same punch.
It's still pleasant,
but it doesn't have the same
overwhelming punch that it did at one
point.
So that would be one suggestion and it's
worth trying.
The other is like make a plan,
I would say do the future authoring
program because it isn't that you're
trying to avoid booze.
Exactly.
It's that you're trying to restructure
your whole life,
you know,
because if you're a drinker then all
your friends are drinkers and,
and you're used to drinking in every
social situation and the places that you
go to socialize or places that you drink
and like it's really built in as a whole
set of habits.
And so what you have to do is kind of
redesign your life.
And you have to think of things.
You can't just stop drinking.
You have to figure out what you're going
to start doing instead of drinking.
There's a hole that you have to fill in.
And you know,
the future authoring program will also
help you figure out what your life could
look like in the absence of alcohol.
And what kind of hell you could end up
in if you keep drinking and it causes
all the problems that it can cause and I
think you really need to like,
you need to think the hail that can
occur and you have to think through how
your life could be valuable with the
alcohol so that you can be motivated
enough to,
to try to regulate it.
And I would also say if you failed and
slip,
don't berate yourself and beat yourself
up.
Just start quitting again because you
know,
if you could cut your alcohol intake
down 75 percent,
that's a hell of lot better than zero.
And often people go all or nothing just
like they do with their quitting
cigarettes.
And in all those quit for a month and
then have a cigarette.
And I say,
Oh my God,
now I'm now I've broken the pact.
And then they'll smoke a whole pack and
they'll be smoking again.
You don't have to do that.
You can just decide that you slipped and
that you're going to get back on the
wagon again.
And no one can take a long time.
But I do believe that you need a better
vision of life,
right?
You have to find something to do that's
better than alcohol,
and that might take some,
some real consideration,
especially if alcohol is a very potent
drug for you.
Then I would also say don't hesitate to
try the NALTREXONE.
It.
It's got a pretty decent clinical
history and it's basically harmless.
So
I've listened carefully to your Cain and
Abel lecture,
but waves of contempt for existence
itself keep coming.
There's a part of me that revels in
riding these waves waves,
but can I harness them for good?
God,
you guys,
you ask the hardest questions.
Waves of contempt of exists for
existence itself.
Keep coming.
Well,
I guess what I would say is
it's probably time for a little bit of
individual psychoanalysis.
I don't necessarily mean that you have
to go and find a therapist.
I would say
you're,
you're generalizing.
You know,
you see waves of contempt for existence
itself.
Keep coming,
but I don't believe that that's exactly
right.
And I'm certainly not accusing you of
being deceitful.
It's,
it's more like low resolution.
My suspicions are is that there's a set
of experiences that you've had that are
characteristic to your own personal life
that have caused you to do caused you
some bitterness and some resentment and
that those haven't been thought through
and usually thinking through means at
least in some part,
trying to take as much responsibility
for those for altering the conditions
under which those things happen going
forward into the future as possible.
Like the purpose of memories to stop you
from doing the same stupid things in the
future.
Right?
That that's the purpose.
And so if you've had experiences that
have made you bitter and resentful or
are still in experiences that are doing
that,
then you need to do a careful micro
analysis of what those are and see if
you can see if you can flip your
attitude in some matter.
You know,
I'm not saying this is easy,
but the first thing you can do is at
least figure out what those memories
are.
And I might recommend trying to pass the
authoring program because what the past
authoring program does is ask you to
break your life up into six parks and
then to identify the emotionally
significant occurrences during each of
those epochs and you can kind of tell if
something needs work from a memory
perspective,
if if it occurred more than about 18
months ago and when you remember it,
it still causes like a wave of sadness
or anger or really any kind of negative
emotion because what that means is that
your brain is still targeting that
experience as threatening and unexplored
and what that means is that in some
sense,
part of you or a part of the that could
exist is still stuck in that memory
because you can go back and do a careful
causal analysis of the events that led
up to the unfortunate circumstance and
try to map out your role and even if
your role is minor,
there's going to be things that you
could have done differently to avoid it.
And that's what you need to figure out
for the future.
I would say you try to shed all your
personal resentment.
A part of that too is to not take,
not take things too personally.
You know,
like one of the advantages of developing
what I would regard as a mythologically
centered view of the cosmos is that you
understand that
the reason there's nothing personal
about the fact that terrible things
happened to you.
I mean,
unless you're directly causally involved
as as it says,
I believe in the Old Testament rains on
the just and the unjust alike and no
there are,
and this is an existentialist motif.
The tragedy and difficulty and even the
confrontation with evil are built into
the structure of existence and it's not
aimed at you personally and it while as
I said,
it may be the price that we pay for
existence itself and you can say,
well that price is too high to pay,
but well,
as I mentioned,
if you start taking that way,
then you make everything much,
much worse.
It seems better to shoulder.
You're cross voluntarily and stumble
forward towards the light.
That's.
That's the best strategy and I would say
that that just because it's the best
strategy doesn't even necessarily mean
that it's always going to work like this
is no optimistic scenario like a dragon
fight is no optimistic scenario.
Confront the dragon and get the gold and
get the girl and bring it back to to
share with the community the gold and
you know that sounds all well and good,
but after all it is a dragon and many
people get eaten by them.
So.
But the myth basically says,
well,
your best bet is to open your eyes and
speak the truth and look forward,
forthright and confront the things that
are the hydrus that are raising their
hands and their tentacles constantly to
frighten you and stop.
You have to fight the tyranny of,
of,
of the social structure when,
when it's oppressing you unduly and,
and that's.
And that's what you have to do.
But I would say if,
if contempt is there now,
now it's really worth digging into
because that,
that would also be the source.
That would be the place where you
discover union shattered because you
would discover depth.
Contempt is an unbelievably destructive
force.
Contempt is a particularly destructive
force and it would be useful for you to
try to think about.
You can use fantasy to do this.
It's like,
okay,
if you let that contempt manifest itself
fully in like a dream or a daydream and
and you let it go on a rampage.
Like what?
What's the vision exactly?
I mean is it the destruction of the
town?
Is the destruction of the country?
Do you want the entire world to blow up
like,
or are there specific people that you're
angry out or maybe you're angry at
yourself,
like you need to figure out those waves
of contempt or unarticulated elements of
experience and they're part of your
shadow.
So can you harness them for good?
Well,
I think the more you understand your
dark urges,
the more likely you are to be able to
regulate and control them and to use
them as part of your power.
When a person or authority,
let's say a person who has authority is
someone who's integrated the dangerous
parts of themselves and that's part of
what gives their words Gravitas and
weight.
And so yes,
I think you could,
you can harness them for good.
It's,
and I think that's the right thing to
do,
but it will involve a fair bit of
painful soul searching.
So.
Okay,
let's see what else we've got here.
Can you hazard a guess where Europe is
clamping down on speech critical of
Islam when Islam is causing lots of
problems with rape,
gangs,
terrorism,
and generally being a menace?
Why?
Well,
I suppose the first,
let's say if I was going to oppose that
statement,
I would say,
well perhaps it's a propaganda stick.
Uh,
what would you call it,
conspiracy to blame what's happening in
Europe on Islamic immigrants?
I guess part of the problem is,
is that at least as far as I can tell,
the news has become sufficiently
unreliable because it's so polarized
that we can't really tell what's going
on.
I mean,
I think the reason that you're at this
time being down on speech,
critical of Islam is partly the same
reason that the entire Western world is
clamping down on speech that's critical
of anything that is associated with
identity,
which
is pretty much any set of ideas that
unites people and it's.
It's a consequence of the collective
decision that we made.
That egalitarianism and a conflict
avoidance constitute the two highest
virtues and they trump everything else
including free speech.
Now why that's happened is very,
very difficult thing to say.
I mean,
I suspect to some degree that it's a
consequence of women becoming involved
in the political system,
which is something that we've never
experienced before and women are more
agreeable
by nature than men and variable.
People are are compassionate towards
those.
They see a suffering and that seems to
include any minority,
especially when you combine that with a
kind of neo Marxist doctrine that claims
that anyone who has an advantage swiped
it.
And I think in the Islamic situation,
you can get it real conflict there
because it's obviously the case that
many Islamic practices are not
commensurate with postmodern neo Marxist
feminism,
let's say,
but they seem to get a free pass and I
guess that's because the idea that all
cultures are equal trumps the
requirement for human rights for women.
And and maybe the other thing that's
even darker is that there's a fair bit
of revolutionary fervor in the more
radical end of the political spectrum
and that radical fervor is devoted
towards tearing down the patriarchy.
And of course that's basically Western
civilization.
And so if,
because Islam isn't part of Western
civilization,
then it can be seen as an ally in that,
in that attempt.
That's what it looks like to me.
I also think that ignorance and all of
that contribute.
It isn't obvious that people who
are afraid of such things as
Islamophobia really understand anything
about Islam.
I wouldn't say I understand anything
about Islam,
even though I've read a fair bit about
it.
It's very difficult to put yourself
inside a different belief system.
I'm somewhat apprehensive about Islam
because it looks to me like it's a
totalizing system as well as a religion
and it's a totalizing system because
everything has to come under his
purview,
including law and and everything that
goes along with that.
There's no separation between church and
state and so I don't see how that's
commensurate with the western mode of
existence and I don't think people want
to have that conversation because they
want to say,
well,
no.
Everyone diverse as they are and
important as that.
Diversity is apparently such that
everyone has to be represented equally.
The diversity isn't really of anything
about anything fundamental and we can
all get along without a problem and
I'm afraid that that's extraordinarily
naive.
And then I suppose there's also an
element of something like Western guilt.
I guess perhaps for what has been
described as our imperialists past
the
that there's been a very longterm
assault
on,
on the,
what would you call moral
on the morality of the West.
We're often viewed as the rapers and
pillagers of the world and that sort of
goes along with the environmentalist
ethos.
And so I think we do have a fair bit of
guilt about that,
whether it's warranted or not.
I mean,
history is a bloody nightmare and it
doesn't matter where you look.
And I would say at least in the west is
brought advantages along with its
disadvantages.
And I think that our attitude towards
individuality is fundamentally correct
and absolutely vital.
And I would also say that the only
countries in the world that are
essentially worth living in,
in any real sense are the ones that are
predicated on the Judeo Christian
tradition and manifested in western the
western body of laws.
So,
but there's still plenty of guilt and
there's plenty of people who,
well,
who are,
what contemptuous of being out as we
discussed in the last question.
And also angry with the political system
because they're powerless or maybe
they've been hurt by male authority
figures.
Um,
that happens very frequently.
And so they have absolutely no trust in
higher in hierarchical structures.
And there you might add to that to
certain amount of laziness because the
thing about hierarchical structures is
that they impose values on people and
then in order to progress in that value
structure that you have to discipline
yourself and work hard.
And many of the radical leftists
happened to be very low in
conscientiousness and so they don't
believe in hard work and they don't
believe that people get to where they're
going by hard work.
And then,
well,
one other thing,
there's a group of people I think who
are basically personality disorder and
in those are the ones that had never had
a positive relationship with anything
that was masculine.
And so whenever they see anything
masculine that has motive power and that
would include authority and competence,
not just power,
they assume that that's tyrannical.
And it's part of the postmodern
assumption that all power higher,
all hierarchies are hierarchies of
power.
When the truth of the matter is,
is that hierarchies in the West are
usually hierarchies of authority and
competence.
And they're like,
they're oriented towards getting a
certain task done and they actually do
get the task done.
So,
but we're,
I'm dubious about our own ethical,
what would you say?
Integrity,
and I guess that's also why it's of
particular importance for people to try
to act honestly,
because if you don't act honestly and
then you start to doubt your own
integrity and then when people come
after you,
you're going to be weak and that's a
really bad idea.
So
how has the online personality tests
coming along?
Can't wait for it.
It's coming along pretty well.
We have all the reports written and we
have the,
um,
the underlying computer architecture
finished,
and at the moment we're just polishing
it up essentially.
And we're hoping that you'll be able to
get a very detailed description of all
five of the big five traits,
right?
Extroversion.
That's a positive emotion dimension.
That's,
that will break down into enthusiasm and
assertiveness and neuroticism.
That breaks down into withdrawal.
Like if you're in a state of withdrawal,
then you're frozen with fear and,
and don't want to do anything.
You're afraid to go out.
You're,
you're afraid to engage in any complex
task because you might fail.
You'll doubt yourself intensely.
That's withdrawal in neuroticism.
And then volatility is that kind of
impulsive touchiness that people often
develop when they're in a bad mood,
you know,
where if you reach your finger up to
touch them,
they'll flinch and maybe slap you and
they're over sensitive to small slights
and they don't have much of a sense of
humor.
Um,
and agreeableness doubt subdivides into
compassion and politeness and the
liberal types are more compassionate and
the conservative types are more polite
and politeness seems to be something
like acting in accordance with the
social norms governing interpersonal
interaction.
Whereas compassion seems to be the
proclivity to side with the weakest
party,
something like that.
And I think it's the primary maternal
dimension because the perhaps along with
higher levels of negative emotion,
because it's obviously the case that
when you're dealing with children,
especially infants,
that you should take the side of the
weaker party pretty much no matter what
the logical argument.
It's right because an infant who's
crying is always right,
especially if it's under a year old.
There's no logic to it.
It's,
it's an a priori fact that a crying
infant is correct.
And so we don't know how that translates
into the political sphere because the
most direct translation would be,
um,
a complaining person is always right.
And,
you know,
I see that manifesting itself,
I would say quite clearly in the
politically correct domain is that you
always side with the person who's
manifesting negative emotion and you
always assume that there's an external
reason that needs to be rectified in
order to,
um,
to deal with that.
And,
you know,
it isn't obvious to me that
agreeableness as an ethic is something
that's transformable into the political
or the adult landscape.
But,
um,
well,
you know,
we don't know these sorts of things and
we can't even talk about them because
people automatically assume that that's
sexist,
misogynist stick or even though there
are agreeable man as well as a grant,
but women,
because men are quite maternal for,
for,
for the kind of large apes and mammals
that we are.
But we need to take these sorts of
things seriously because it isn't
obvious to me that in an ethic of
agreeableness can govern a complex
politics.
Looks to me more like conscientiousness
is something that needs to govern arm's
length,
transactions and that sort of thing.
Rather than treating everyone like kin,
which you just can't do so you don't
have the energy.
Anyways.
The test will also associate
conscientious or assess
conscientiousness.
That's orderliness,
which is seems to be associated with
disgust,
sensitivity and is a good predictor of
conservative belief and industriousness,
which is something like the well,
it's what it says exactly.
It's the proclivity to engage in
effortful work towards a defined goal in
a reliable manner and it's the second
best predictor of longterm life success
after Icu.
And then the final thing it'll upset,
assesses openness to experience which is
more or less half creativity at half
interest in ideas.
And so if you take the test,
you'll get a boat up.
It's about a 10 page report and sketch
quite detailed and it tells you where
you fit on a percentile basis and what
your strengths and weaknesses are going
to be as a consequence.
And we're going to produce a couple's
version so that two of you can take it
and then you'll get a report that tells
you how you're similar and different and
where you're likely to to have
disagreements and agreements where it's
going to be difficult to negotiate a
consensus that'd be where your Wyatt
widely different from one another on a
trait that gets hard for an extrovert
and an introvert to come to an agreement
about how much socializing they're going
to do because the extrovert says,
well,
let's socialize all the time.
In the introvert says,
well,
you know,
once a year would be plenty for me and
those aren't opinions right there.
They're built in preferences that are
far beneath the realm of opinion and if
you're high in openness and your partner
is low in openness,
like you're going to be interested in
the theater and arts and literature and
philosophy and and talking about ideas
and and going to museums and that sort
of thing.
And your partner is in some sense it
will be like they're colorblind.
They just won't find that sort of thing
engaging and interesting at all.
And you might be able to shift someone a
little bit to a higher degree of
openness,
but it's,
it's,
it's not an easy thing to do.
So we think in the literature seems to
indicate that you should be fairly well
matched on most of your traits with your
partner,
uh,
with the possible exception of
neuroticism because it isn't obvious
that two people are highly neurotic,
can get along.
Uh,
neuroticism is a pretty good predictor
of marital unhappiness,
just like it's a good predictor of every
other form of unhappiness.
So
Benjamin would says,
my room is a den of iniquity.
Well,
congratulations.
That's not an easy thing to pull off.
I guess you might be asking yourself,
what's that student for you?
Obviously you're being funny and that's
just fine.
So
what advice would you give to someone
looking to quit porn?
Well,
I gave some advice a little earlier
about quitting alcohol.
And I would say it isn't that you're
trying to quit porn.
It's not the right way to think about
it.
The right way to think about it is that
you're trying to figure out how to have
a better life.
And so you have to figure out,
well,
I would say do the future authoring
program and keep your porn addiction in
mind and think so in the first part of
the future authoring program,
it asks you a bunch of questions about
what your life could be like in three to
five years if you took care of yourself
like you were someone that you cared
for,
um,
and then it asks you questions about
your friends and your family and your
career and your time outside of work and
your health and you know,
the important dimensions of life and it,
it asks you to spend
20 minutes writing about how good your
life could be in three to five years if
you got your act together and did what
was good for you.
And then it asked you to write about the
hail you could be in if you didn't.
And so I would say you really need to do
that because porn isn't the issue.
The issue is that you're not living your
life the way you want to.
And so you need a vision of life that's
more compelling than the porn.
And you need a counter vision to that
frightens you know,
because otherwise porn is obviously
extraordinarily gratifying in the short
term,
but,
but you seem to be suffering from the
medium to longterm consequences of its
use.
And so you need a story that you can
tell yourself that's really deeply
thought through about why this is not
appropriate for you.
What's what?
It's how it's hurting you and how it's
minimizing you admit perhaps making you
embarrassed and ashamed and more
socially isolated and all of that.
So I would say think about it as
cleaning up your psyche and your
behavior rather than merely start
stopping,
stopping poor.
And you also might want to write down
and you could do this in the negative
vision part of the future authoring
program.
You got to write down everything bad
that you think porn is doing to you
because obviously you have some
suspicions that this is not good for
you,
right?
That it's,
it's actually harming you in some
important way and so you need to be
fully cognizant of what those ways are
and then take them seriously and decide
if that's the pathway through life.
On which you wish to travel and so and
then I would also say good luck to you.
You know,
it's,
it's a very good idea to identify one of
your weaknesses and work on time.
You can.
You can strengthen yourself
substantially by doing that.
Is there a way to take any of your
classes online?
Will you be establishing an online
university?
Well,
there's no way at the moment to take any
of my classes online for credit,
which I presume is what you're asking
you.
All the lectures that I've done for the
classes are online on youtube for many
of the classes so you can get the
information and you can do the reading
but you can't be accredited for it and
that's partly due to University of the
University of Toronto hasn't set up the
university to make that a
straightforward thing yet.
And the accreditation problem is a big
one.
Will you be establishing an online
university?
Well,
you know,
that depends.
It depends.
My health has been uneven for a
substantial amount of time and when it's
down as it is right now,
I'm probably only five percent as
productive as I am when it's,
when I'm functioning at full bore,
I seem to have developed a series of or
discovered a series of food
sensitivities that I share with my
daughter and it's very,
uh,
the reaction to eating the wrong thing
is extremely vicious.
Basically flattens me out for a month.
Um,
I can't think properly and I can't
organize my actions.
And so
I would really very much like to pursue
this idea of an online university.
And I've talked to many people about it,
but it's a very complex project and to a
large degree it's going to be dependent
on the state of my health.
When I'm healthy,
I can do a very large number of things
simultaneously and I'm very enthusiastic
about them and very efficient.
But when I'm not,
it's,
it's.
I really wonder if I'm even going to be
able to keep up the minimal
responsibilities necessary to keep my
life in order.
And that's actually very terrifying
thought.
So I'd love to do it,
you know,
and I would also say I'm starting it to
some degree because I believe these
biblical lectures are crucial to the
establishment of something like an on
line humanities university because I
believe that like our culture is made up
of strata of stories that might be a
good way of thinking about it.
Like hierarchy,
the levels of stories and the base story
is definitely the stories that are laid
out in the Bible for better or for
worse.
And in order to understand our culture,
I think you have to have a grounding.
You have to be grounded in an
understanding of the Bible.
And I'm trying to make that as a
religious in some sense as possible.
Not necessarily because I believe that
an a religious approach to the Bible is
the most appropriate,
but because I want to investigate it
with the least amount of metaphysical
baggage possible.
And I'm hoping in that way to help
people stabilize their identities.
To eliminate the idea of the development
of the divine individual.
Which I think is Western culture is
glorious contribution to human
civilization.
And the thing that lifted us all out of
slavery and,
and,
and penury and serfdom and,
and all of those subordinate roles into
the society of relatively free and
autonomous individuals that we are today
and we can't let that doe and I think it
will go unless we have something very
strong metaphysically at the bottom.
I think we're weak without it because we
fractionate and everybody believes a
thousand different things and it's sorta
like,
you know,
you saw what happened to that.
Um,
Wall Street protest,
occupy Wall Street,
right?
I mean,
it's no wonder people were irritated
about what happened in 2008.
Although periodic financial collapses
are pretty common and it isn't always
obvious who to blame.
A lot of that was innovation driven as
it turned out law.
Some of it was corruption,
but some of them was just unbridled
innovation.
And because like the mortgage tronches
were very brilliant in some sense,
but they had unexpected consequences.
But in any case,
you know,
there was a protest against the fact
that,
well,
the bulk of the catastrophe seemed to
fall on the poor,
which is of course always the case,
but there was no organization whatsoever
on the side of the Wall Street Occupy
Wall Street protesters.
They,
they believed such a wide variety of
things that they are unable to to
organize themselves in any effective
manner.
And basically as far as I can tell,
all they did was go out and indicate
that they were displeased.
But that's not a very effective strategy
because if you're displeased and even if
you're displeased for a reason and a
valid reason,
you still need to have some sense of
what it would be that would rectify
that.
Because otherwise there's no.
There's no movement forward.
So anyway,
so part of the reason I'm doing the
biblical lectures,
which I think are perhaps the most
important thing I'm doing and I hope to
continue because of that is because I
want to do whatever I can to give those
stories,
their due credit and to investigate very
thoroughly the manner in which the
literary imagination of Western
civilization that Judeo Christian
tradition manifested itself to produce
the idea of the autonomous invaluable
individual.
Right?
Because that's our magic idea,
man.
That's at the basis of everything that
we do.
So I guess I'm going to be contributing
to the online university in that manner.
I'm going to try the other,
but I can't promise anything because for
the reasons that I already indicated we
were thinking of one tactic.
I don't know what you guys think about
this,
but I was thinking very interesting.
First course might be like a five hour
introduction to the history of the
cosmos.
And so I was talking with my brother in
law who would be willing to fund some of
this along with me.
Um,
and maybe with some crowdfunding we'd
like to host a competition.
You know,
so,
and the competition would be for the
best five,
our summary of the history of the cosmos
from the Big Bang to the present and we
would lay it wide open for people with
regards to what sort of technology they
wanted to use,
whether it was animation or lecture or
readings or whatever,
and to offer like a $10,000 first prize
and a $5,000 second prize and a $3,000
third prize,
something like that.
And then maybe get people to vote on
which,
um,
you know,
which production was of the highest
quality.
And because what should happen with the
online university I think is that we
should set up a way of funding creative
content producers instead of maybe
focusing on the content itself because
there's thousands of people out there
who are very educated and who are
perhaps even underemployed,
who have very specific expertise,
who could make courses.
And there's just no reason not to
harness that.
And so anyways,
we've been thinking about it a lot,
but the bottom line is,
um,
how function light am or become over the
next while.
Because I'm certainly,
like I said,
I'm only running at about five percent
at the moment and it's,
uh,
it,
it stops me from certainly stops me from
enthusiastic tackling extraordinarily
difficult problems with starting an
online university.
So I think the,
this year has taken a reasonable toll on
me.
And also this dietary sensitivity issue
is
complicated beyond belief.
I can't really go out and eat and it's
very difficult to travel and if I eat
the wrong thing,
I'm basically in some variant of health
for about a month.
So
anyhow,
we'll see.
We'll see how that all goes.
What do you make of the manosphere is
claimed that women's liberation has led
to our weakened ability to pair bond,
the breakdown of the institution of
marriage and sexual inequity in favor of
Alpha men?
Well,
you know,
I guess probably I would say that to the
degree that all of that is true,
I wouldn't say that the Women's
liberation movement is what's done it
because I don't believe that the Women's
liberation movement is the primary
driver of Women's liberation.
In fact,
I think it's a secondary consequences of
far more radical biological revolution.
Now it's the invention of the birth
control pill,
right,
because the birth control pill
essentially allowed females for the
first time in evolutionary history to
gain voluntary control over the
reproductive function and a tremendous
amount of political upheaval followed in
the aftermath of that and you know,
people who are engaged in that political
upheaval like to think about it as
causal because they like to think that
their,
their efforts say on agitating in favor
of of women's equal rights.
It was actually the causal factor that
produced the sociological
transformation.
But I think the evidence for that is
extraordinarily weak given me
unbelievable magnitude of the birth
control pill.
So with the birth control pill,
women become more like men,
much more like man.
And also it seems to be the case that
women on the birth control pill don't
like masculine men as much.
There's studies showing that,
for example,
if you show women in the face of it are
the same man at different or the same
men at different phases of their
dilatory cycle and all you do is widen
the Gr,
narrow the job of the men that the women
are at the peak of their observation
where they're maximally fertile like the
wide jaw men better,
but when they're infertile,
they liked the narrow John mid better
and wider jog.
Men have higher levels of testosterone
and and the pill mimics infertility and
so you know,
we don't know what these radical,
biological,
hormonal transformations have done to
the relationship between men and women
and you know,
women too are trying to experiment with
their new mode of being.
It's like,
well now they're not destined at an
early age to become,
to transform themselves into mothers or
to be,
or to allow themselves to be transformed
by nature into mother's even though it's
possible that they might be much happier
if that happened.
I'm not saying that that's necessarily
the case,
but there is good evidence that women's
general level of unhappiness has
increased since the early 19 sixties.
So,
um,
you know,
anyways,
what has been the consequences of that?
Well,
the first consequence was wild sexual
experimentation and why not?
What would you expect?
It's like all of a sudden reproductions
under control.
What does that mean?
That women can be as promiscuous as men?
Well,
maybe that's what it means.
We don't know.
So that was part of the big sixties
experiment and it isn't the obviously
obvious that that went particularly
well.
Um,
it certainly led to the pornography
location of our society,
which I think is been,
I really think is actually quite
dreadful.
Um,
maybe that's my innate prudishness,
but I don't know what seems to me that
pornography demeans the participants as
well as the viewers.
There's something second rate and
furtive about it and I think that
everybody who engages in it knows that,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's an,
it's a substitute for the real adventure
of life.
And I do think that it leads to a
certain kind of a,
perhaps contempt.
It leads to contempt,
I would say.
Um,
and,
and that can't be a good thing.
I mean,
I don't ever think,
and you guys can ask yourself this
question.
Have you ever met anybody who can finish
masturbating and then was proud about it
and who stood up straighter because of
it?
If you felt that they'd really conquered
life as a consequence?
I mean,
I just don't believe that that's the,
that that's the general post
masturbation feeling.
I don't believe that.
I believe that it's,
it's,
it's like a,
it's something you do when you,
when you don't have the right thing to
do and it's an admission that you're a
second player essentially.
Something like that.
So the pornography location was a bad
thing.
Um,
the fact that women's lives have been
complicated too,
I would say buy this,
buy this transformation to.
Because it isn't easy now for women to
decide that they want to make being a
mother a primary focus of their life.
Because increasingly it's necessary for
families to have two incomes.
And I think the reason for that,
there's two reasons for that.
One is that when women started to flood
into the labor market was approximately
the same time that the market started to
open to places like India and China and
working wages started to flatten.
But then you also have the fact that if
you doubled the labor pool by
introducing women into it,
perhaps you half the value of labor and
that might maybe do even worse than
that.
If women are more agreeable and more
likely to work part time and more
willing to take lesser hours and lower
pay,
which seems to be the case,
then maybe you flatten the labor market
even more so in terms of increasing
sexual inequity in favor of Alpha Man.
Well,
anything that Breaks Down Pair Bonding
matrimony is going to do that because,
um,
you know,
sexual access for males is a prieto
distributed phenomena where a small
proportion of the males get most of the
invitations,
let's say.
And the thing that is a bulwark against
that is,
is monogamy.
And part of the reason that societies
are set up to be monogamous is so that
that proclivity is controlled because
it's not good for children,
let's say if,
if they don't have access to a and it's
not good for women if they're all
competing for the same man and then it's
not good for the men who aren't being
chosen because they're not being chosen.
And so that just seems to be a recipe
for resentment and,
and,
and aggression.
And I think the evolutionary psychology
data on that,
it's pretty clear.
So
that's what I would say.
I don't think it's the women's
liberation,
it's the birth control pill.
And um,
you know,
don't underestimate the significance of
the birth control pill.
It's like the hydrogen bomb or that or
the computer chip.
It's a world revolutionary technology.
And for all we know it might do us in,
you know,
I mean in the West,
the birth rate is far below replacement.
And you know,
that's as a,
as a multigenerational strategy.
That's just,
that's an absolute dead end.
And of course,
no one can talk about that because,
well,
for obvious the obvious reasons of
egalitarianism and diversity and all of
that,
but the declining birth rate in the West
is really,
I would say a catastrophe.
I don't have to be one of those people
who think the planet has too many people
on it,
you know.
So
you have said that the humanity become
corrupt and for a person to avoid the
dangers of the postmodern,
neo Marxist ideologies and not enroll.
Would you agree the same applies to the
institute of marriage with laws as they
are?
No,
I wouldn't say that.
I guess partly because I don't
understand what the alternative is.
I mean,
first I would say that to the degree
that men are just your unjustly upset
about the way the marriage laws are set
up and I think they have reason to be
concerned,
especially with regards to the custody
of children and the probability of
paying virtually endless alimony with
unbelievably severe penalties for
failure.
I think that it's incumbent on men to
organize themselves politically and
rectify that.
And so I don't think that the answer is
avoiding marriage.
I think the answer is political
organization and pressure on the right
institutions to rectify this because it
needs to be rectified.
And I don't like the idea of telling
young men to avoid permanent
relationships with women because as far
as I'm concerned,
this is my traditional wisdom.
I suppose manifesting itself.
There aren't that many pathways to life.
You know,
you need a career,
you need,
you need an interesting things to do
with your,
with your time outside of your career,
interesting and meaningful things.
You need a family,
you need an intimate relationship to
twine yourself together with someone
else so that well,
so that you're protected during times of
crisis and able to celebrate during
times of joy and,
and,
and so you set up a stable structure so
that you can have children and have them
feel secure and unable to play.
And like that's life man.
And if you miss any of that,
then your life is fragmented and
fractured it and you're going to be
hurt.
And I'm not saying that's absolutely
true for every single person.
There's always exceptions,
but I'm concerned with the bulk of
people and the and what the bulk of
people have already done and like your
life just isn't in some ways that
complicated.
You need to bear a social weight,
you need to have a family and commit
yourself to that and it's in those
commitments that you find the meaning in
your life and so if you don't have them
then while you float and drift and,
and when people float and drift,
they usually don't float somewhere good
and they usually drift somewhere bad.
So I think that there are problems with
the way the marriage laws are set up.
I think they're quite serious.
I don't think.
I do think that they
persecute men often,
but I don't think the answer to that is
to tell young men to avoid permanent
relationships with young women at all
costs because that isn't very anti life
doctrine and it's a cure that's worse
than the disease.
That's what I would say.
I'm beginning to sort myself out.
Thanks to you.
While I'm very glad to hear that.
I have a question about scheduling your
time trying to make a schedule and a
chaotic job with constantly changing
shifts and hours tips,
or should I find a new job altogether?
Well,
you know,
I don't,
I can't answer that Josh because I don't
know enough about the details of your
life,
but what I would say,
and maybe you've tried this already,
is you know,
try to make two plans.
Okay.
Because when you're,
when you're trying to think something
like this through,
you need to think it through in detail.
And so one plan would be how you would
conduct your life optimally and organize
your time if you kept your current job
and you want to make that as acceptable
and positive as possible and then make
out another plan where you shift jobs
and you have no,
maybe a more stable working arrangement
and then think about what your life
would be like if you had that.
And then because you've laid out a
detailed map of both,
you're in a much better position to
compare them.
And so,
um,
you know,
you might need to talk to somebody about
that too.
But that's what I would recommend
because it's just too complicated a job,
like if you find that your sleep is
chronically disrupted and you can
organize your life,
the fact that shift changes,
no trivial thing and it can really throw
your mood regulation for a loop too.
And I don't know if that's happening to
you,
not,
but that's also something else that's
worth taking into consideration.
But I say map out an alternative reality
where you don't have those problems and
see how much better that looks,
you know,
I presume there's some advantages to
your current job.
So when it also depends on what your
options are,
like how hard would it be for you to
find another job and couldn't find a
job.
Like maybe the best thing to do would be
to try to find a job that's better,
that doesn't have shifts,
you know,
and maybe that'll take you a year or two
that can be very difficult,
but you know,
a year or two,
is it a shorter period of time?
Often that it seemed.
So that's what I would recommend.
So
your idea of realer than real appears to
parallel Plato's theory of the forms.
Is this the source of the idea or are
you reconceived and ancient philosophy?
Well,
God only knows what the source of an
idea is,
you know,
um,
my sense of plato's forms was it was
that they weren't exactly narrative
instructure,
although I think that I think that there
isn't at least an analogous relationship
between the idea of archetypes and the
idea of formed.
Um,
I think plato was talking more about
forms of,
of tangible objects in the world,
you know,
where I'm talking more about permanent
patterns of behavior,
you know,
because
what are,
what our culture is essentially is a
dance of permanent patterns of behavior.
I mean,
there's a fair bit of variability in
the,
in the patterns.
Like there is variability in a
basketball game or a soccer game or
something like that.
You know,
there's obviously predictability and
variability,
but,
um,
what's the predictable elements are the,
or equivalent in some sense to the
platonic forms,
which is the point that you're making.
And it's the discovery of those more
permanent forms that emerges as a
consequence of the spinning of stories,
you know,
because we're watching each other
constantly and we're articulating what
we see and then we're amalgamating the
articulations and we're sifting them
for,
for fundamental patterns.
And like a good example of that.
It's something that I just recently
discovered when I did the biblical
lectures on Abraham.
You know,
I didn't understand that Abraham was a
late bloomer.
You know,
he was like the guy who stayed in his
mother's basement for too long.
I mean,
he's 75 when God calls him on an
adventure.
And God basically tells him to leave his
family and his countrymen in his kinsmen
and to go into the land of the stranger.
And that's.
See there's an archetypal pattern there.
And the pattern is,
well,
it's the pattern of the call and it's
deeply,
it's something that people experienced,
you know,
like an adolescent,
healthy adolescent wants to get away
from his or her stultifying a dependent
upbringing and go out into the world of
adventure.
And you know,
in the biblical stories that's,
that's symbolically represented as
something akin to a divine call,
which,
which I think is quite interesting
because you know,
we don't understand these calls,
you know,
you have an impulse to do something.
Something captures your interest.
Something captures your motivation.
It's,
it's not like it's self generated.
Exactly.
You know,
the,
the idea that the call to adventure is
produced by something like a
transcendent deity is a really
interesting idea.
Now.
It depends on what you mean by data.
You know,
you can think about it as an ancient
brain circuit,
I suppose,
although I don't know if that really
makes it things any clearer,
but there is an impulse within people
that pulls them out into the world to go
away from their safe circumstances and
to make their fortunate where there's
famine and tyranny and,
and threats to the integrity of the
family,
which are all things that Abraham
immediately encounters when he listens
to God.
And so that seems to be something like
something that's realer than real
because everyone experiences that to
some degree or everyone can relate to
it.
It's a deep,
deep theme and you know,
what I'm looking for in the biblical
stories,
in other mythological representations is
these deep universal themes.
Now is that a reconceptualization of
ancient philosophy?
It's really hard to say because,
you know,
I derived the idea of the archetype,
at least in part from reading new and
young of course was influenced because
he had a great classical education by
the ancients.
And so exactly where these ideas come
from isn't clear.
So,
um,
so I guess that's pretty much all I have
to say about that.
Nothing motivates me aside from eating
and sleeping.
I lie in my bed all day,
no one on my computer,
not on my phone,
not doing anything.
I just lie there thinking what's
happening to me.
I would say that you are,
and this is not a diagnostic comment and
I don't know enough about you to provide
that sort of information,
but I would recommend that you see a
therapist and be screened for depression
because that's what it looks like to me.
And I would say that if it's depression,
you should do something about it because
depression is very hard on people.
It produces a lot of stress hormones
like cortisol and that can hurt you in
May,
you know,
if it's only been a couple of days I
wouldn't worry about it.
But if it's a chronic pattern then you
should go talk to somebody,
even your family doctor,
you know,
and there's always the possibility that
a low dose of an antidepressant might be
worth trying,
you know,
in a month if it fixed you.
But I would say don't,
don't stay in that situation,
man.
Go,
go find out,
do whatever you have to do to get out of
it.
And especially the fact that you're not
on your computer and no one on your
phone not doing anything,
you know,
you're,
you're ruminating,
that's just lying there thinking that's
loops of negative emotion and you don't
have any positive emotion,
you know,
that's why you're not on your computer
or your phone.
And so one of the characteristics of
depression or I suppose to have the
characteristics is a decrease in
positive motivation.
And so that means that you're not
interested in anything and an increase
in negative emotion and that can
manifest itself in that I'm just lying
there thinking,
you know,
so go talk to someone,
go talk to someone,
tell someone that this is happening,
gift to your family doctor,
let them know what's happening,
get them to give you a depression
screening and uh,
and see what you can do about it because
there are effective treatments for
depression.
And sometimes antidepressants work like
a absolute charm
to tap into the dopaminergic system.
You said you needed to value goal.
Is there any way to tap into the opioid
system?
I want to be more connected to people,
but part of me can't get myself to care.
Okay.
Well,
one of the things that,
so maybe you're a little bit on the
disagreeable side,
that's a possibility.
There's some interesting clinical
evidence that suggests that one of the
things that disagreeable people can do
in order to facilitate their
interactions with other people is to do
people favors.
And so what you might say is that you
could start by acting like you care.
And then maybe you could learn how to
care through doing that,
so maybe you could say,
well I'm going to do something nice for
someone once every two days for a month
and,
and think about it a little bit and see
what,
see if that changes you because you
know,
sometimes you think yourself into change
and sometimes you act yourself into
changing your thoughts.
And so that's what I would start by
doing.
And you know,
you could also be more connected to
people regardless of whether you care,
you know,
let's say that it would take you six
months of practice or even a year of
practice before you cared.
But that's not so long,
especially if you're young.
So
that's what I say about that.
Do we know if Dr Peterson has just been
overrun by his emails?
I thought he would find meaningful,
but people are telling me it's unlikely
to leave and see it.
So.
Oh,
well I guess,
yeah.
Well I'm so overwhelmed by my email that
it's just unbelievable.
I mean,
I,
I probably have 10,000 emails that are
unanswered and you know,
at some point I just,
I wouldn't say exactly that I gave up,
but that's close enough,
you know,
I'm trying to respond to the ones that
will destroy my life if I don't respond
to them,
but,
and it's really sad because um,
people are sending me really good
letters and I've been trying to think of
a method of having someone go through my
email to identify the letters that are
unbelievably help,
heartfelt and valuable because it's a
shame to miss them.
But,
um,
I just haven't had any choice,
you know,
basically except when I'm not feeling
well.
Like,
no,
I'm basically working from seven in the
morning til 11 at night trying to finish
my book,
which I have to page proofs for now.
So that's getting closer to keep,
to keep up with my obligations,
including making the videos and I'm
preparing the biblical lectures and
trying to zip here and there and talk.
So I'm very sorry that to all of you.
I'm sure that many of you have written
me letters and that you've put a lot of
heart and soul into them and thanking
me.
You were describing a problem that you
have or,
or a solution that you've generated or
ideas and I really feel bad that I can't
answer them,
but I can't.
So at some point you just think,
well,
that's just how it goes.
You know,
you're,
you can't do what you can do when
there's no sense being overwhelmingly
tormented by it.
So,
um,
that's,
that's the situation.
So please don't take it personally.
So
Dr Peterson,
I am considering going into the
education stream slash system.
Do you have any advice for me not to
become a mouthpiece for indoctrinating
young students?
Well,
one thing I would recommend is that you
don't write essays that you don't
believe in.
I think that's a sin.
I think it's a sin to use your words
falsely.
And the reason for that,
like there's a good series of social
psychology experiments that show,
like imagine that you bring someone into
a lab and you have them write an essay
about or fill out a questionnaire about
their political opinions,
you know,
so you get a baseline measure of their
political stance and then you ask them
to write a thousand words,
maybe they identify as right wing,
and then you get them to write a
thousand word essay on why a particular
left wing position is true.
And then you have them come back in two
weeks and you give them the same
political belief questionnaire they'll
tell have shifted quite radically
towards the left.
And the reason for that is that people
don't think through their positions in
great detail.
And so if you get them to think through
a contrary position in great detail,
then that starts to become more
convincing.
And so if you go into a field like
education,
that's really,
I'm pathologically overrun by the
postmodern,
neo Marxist types.
You're going to experience a tremendous
amount of pressure to falsify your
words.
You're going to be afraid that if you
don't do that,
you're going to fail and maybe sometimes
you will be punished by a professor,
but I would say in most circumstances,
I'm still optimistic enough to believe
that if you write a good essay that
isn't ideologically proper,
you'll still get a good grade.
I guess I would say if you write a good
essay that's not ideologically proper
and you do get a good grade,
that's probably a good time to fight.
So because you either fight or
capitulate,
right?
That's,
that's the.
That's the hard truth.
So I'm not saying it would be easy and I
would also say don't make unnecessary
enemies,
right?
You don't.
Everything doesn't have to be a battle,
but now and then you're going to know
that you know,
you'll hate writing the essay because
you have to sacrifice your soul in order
to put the words down and then you,
you,
you demand to warp your character and
you just don't recover easily from that.
So I would say,
don't do that,
man.
That's not good.
Have you ever dressed professor Kevin?
Mcdonald's work on an ethnic conflict
theory of Judaism as a group,
evolutionary strategy,
visa vi gentile societies.
It's very provocative,
but I find much of it persuasive.
Have you read any of his work?
This is going to be a very disappointing
answer.
I'm afraid because the answer is no.
I haven't read any of his work,
so I'm afraid I'm not going to be able
to answer that question unfortunately,
so apologies for that.
I've definitely.
I've recently developed a nasty case of
hypno phobia and generally suffer from
anxiety surrounding sleep.
It's become a significant negative force
in my life,
cause unknown.
I'm rather well put together and
successful across many domains.
Any advice?
Yes,
go to bed later.
So one of the things that happens to
people when they're having a hard time
going to sleep and their sleep is
disrupted,
is that they tend to go to bed earlier
to catch up on their sleep and that
actually has a counter that's cut that
works at counter purposes to what
they're trying to attempt.
What you want to do is delay your sleep
until you're really quite tired.
So stay up much later.
Get up at the same time in the morning
game,
but move your sleep time later,
maybe half an hour night until you
actually do fall asleep.
Um,
the other thing that you could look into
is that there are relaxation exercises.
Behavior therapists offer those,
but I'm sure you could find one online
and breathing exercise.
And so often what you do is imagine
you're laying in your bed and you're
nervous and so what you do is you
concentrate on your feet and you flex
your and then breathe in and out and
relax them.
And then you flex your ankles or the
soles of your feet and,
and breathe in and out and relax and do
that with every muscle group all the way
up your body and remember to breathe
deeply and regularly and that can help
regulate your anxiety.
So I would say stay up later till you're
clearly tired.
The other thing you might try and
sleeping in a different room.
And then the final thing is there aren't
pretty effective sleep medications like
Zappos for example.
It just seems to be pretty effective.
And if you're really having a hard time
sleeping,
maybe you could try something like that
and see if it and see if it helps.
You don't have to try it forever.
But so the simplest thing to do though
is to go to bed later and because you'll
be more tired and more likely to fall
asleep then,
and it's really not going to cause you
any trouble.
So that's what I recommend.
What do we do once our ego has helped us
plan the dominance hierarchy to secure a
mate?
Why then should we keep looking for a
mate and how to curtail that instinct?
Well,
I think part of the way that you curtail
that in state is that you have,
you have this sort of life that you
would have with a mate.
The question is,
what's the purpose of pair bonding?
And one of the fundamental purposes of
pair bonding,
well,
there's a couple.
One is that it solves the sexual access
problems so that you don't have to
continue to obsess about who you're
going to be within and,
and,
and where,
and how.
And so you can get on with other
elements of your life,
but I mean with,
with your meat,
you have to decide what,
what does it mean that you're now
together,
you know,
what year it was,
companionship.
Obviously in friendship and their shared
interests,
you have to decide what they are and I
would say that you should continue
dating your,
your partner at least once a week or
perhaps twice a week because otherwise
the romance goes out of your life.
But then also you have to decide about
children and and eventually about
grandchildren because you know you're
going to get them old and new.
You're going to get older and more
mature and children are a huge part of
life and they get a bad rap.
Which is really unfortunate because,
you know,
maybe I'm different in this regard.
Perhaps I am to some degree,
but I never regretted having kids for
even one second because there are so
mean.
All of a sudden you have an intimate
relationship with new people.
That is as close as any relationship
that you've ever had.
You have the opportunity to make that
relationship as pristine as you possibly
can mean.
It can be a lot of catastrophe involved
in it,
but it's a great opportunity and there's
just nothing wrong with having some
additional people that love you,
you know,
and so what you do is you turn your
attention to the issues of maturity and
your junior year attention away from the
issues of being a juvenile and you do
that partly by knowing that it's
actually better to do so.
You know there's nothing more absurd
than the 40 year old 20 year old.
It gets ugly and there's something like.
There's something like spoiled milk
about it.
It goes off and you have to gracefully
accept the challenges of each stage of
life and things work a lot better when
you do that much,
much better and you also have to,
I would say,
work on and perfect your sex life with
your partner and express what you need
and want and teach each other what's
necessary to keep things exciting and
and and new.
It's not an easy thing to do,
but it's very much worthwhile because
then you can combine sexual excitement
with intimacy and there's no better
combination than that.
So,
and love that.
It can all be nested inside love and
inside in our destiny that's intertwined
together.
That's the best you've got,
man.
That's,
that's,
that's what life has to offer.
And so,
um,
that's what you do is you accept the
responsibility of the next stage of life
and you don't mourn the past.
I suppose that also means that when
you're young you do what young people do
and so that you don't want to do it
again.
So
I need to ask a very serious question.
Pickles are green olives.
Hm?
That's a tough one.
Um,
at the moment I can't eat pickles so I'd
have to go with green all upside.
Do you really like green olives?
Especially if they're spicy.
So I'd probably,
if I had to make a choice it would be a
tough one,
but I think I'd probably go with green
olives.
So
do you have any advice for someone who
may be asexual?
I want to have a husband and children,
but I'm 27 and haven't felt a connection
with anyone.
I'm just seeing everyone as friends so
far in life.
Well,
he might want to see a sex therapist
that might help.
Um,
I guess the other thing I would say as
well,
you know,
it might not be too bad an idea to,
um,
act out what you want perhaps in the
absence of any necessary desire.
Like,
you know,
you might be so far have fallen so far
inside yourself.
Then it's very difficult to get out.
Um,
what are sex therapist would do,
would be in,
once you were in some kind of,
let's say,
friendship that you wanted to move
forward would be to have you guys
practice interacting in an intimate
manner,
stage by stage so that you could get
accustomed to it,
you know,
so you need to explore whether that's
essential reality as you say,
or if it's fear or if it's,
you know,
it might be fear of rejection,
it might be fear of sexuality might be
that you're slow to warm up and
introverted.
Um,
but I think seeing a sex therapist might
not be a bad idea,
you know,
I guess the other thing,
and I say this with some hesitation,
is that if you find someone you like
that you could be friends with,
I mean,
you could try.
I'm initiating a romantic relationship
and practice it for a couple of months
and see what happens because,
you know,
maybe you'd warm up across time.
It's certainly,
it's certainly a,
it's certainly a possibility.
So
I have systemic juvenile idiopathic
arthritis.
Do you mentioned your daughter has
something akin to it in a diet?
Helped him with her fatigue.
May I ask what diet she used cheers from
Calgary if you go to,
if you look up mckayla Peterson don't
eat that,
that's her blog,
don't eat that.
And she has a lot of advice there about
diets that you could try and,
and uh,
you know,
I would say do it with some hesitation
in Catia,
but um,
that,
that uh,
that seemed to help her a lot.
So do you plan your day much or your
time generally?
Does this lead to higher productivity?
Yes,
I plan my day obsessively.
My calendar is always absolutely full
and often weeks in advance and I plan in
the morning,
especially when I'm on top of things.
So.
And I plan each hour and I probably plan
each minute and yes,
it leads to way higher productivity.
You,
you decide what your goals are going to
be.
You place them in the calendar,
use the calendar as your friend day
because what you want to do with the
calendar is designed a day that you want
to have or a day that would be good for
you in a day that would be good for you,
is one that you're,
that you're,
um,
you know,
when you end the day,
you feel that you've moved,
moved yourself ahead towards your
values,
goals and that you've kept chaos under
control and that enables you to sleep
soundly and with a good conscience.
And to know that the next day is going
to be at least not worse than that.
Date.
Planning is unbelievably useful.
And again,
you know,
I,
I don't want to sound like a broken
record with regards to the future
authoring program,
but it really is useful.
You know,
you need to figure out what it is that
you're aiming at and why.
And then you need to figure out how
you're going to break that down over the
months and the weeks and the days.
But I would approach your calendar like
it's your best friend,
do you think,
okay,
I'm going to design a weak man that I
really want to have and that means you
can schedule in leisure and all the
things that you want to do,
which would,
you absolutely should do.
And it's also quite to,
um,
give yourself minimal time to do
something complicated because it's quite
challenging to see if you can do far
more than you thought in far less time.
And so that's a fun game.
And the other thing you can do is like,
if you're avoiding something,
you could schedule in five minutes of it
and say,
well,
like if you're avoiding looking at some
bills because you're afraid of them,
you know,
your first step might be to schedule in
five minutes where you just look at the
bill,
you don't do anything else and you know,
you might be able to entice yourself
into doing that.
So,
but I would say learning to plan is
unbelievably useful to schedule your
time because that's your life,
you know,
um,
but scheduled the life you want,
that means you have to schedule your
responsibilities often,
obviously,
because responsibilities are those
things that ruin your life if you don't
fulfill them.
So,
um,
all right,
safety advisor,
northern Alberta,
asking what's the best personality tests
for my coworker,
ground level of management.
Any recommended practices to promote
mental health with remote workers?
Well answered the first part of that
using big five personality test.
Um,
what my camera just like trucks.
Sorry about that guys.
I'm back.
Hopefully everything is functioning
again.
Question,
how is capitalism compatible with your
definition of good?
If it requires ever increasing uses of
the finite resources of the planet,
where once depleted would mean our end.
Well,
I would say capitalism isn't compatible
with my definition of good if it
requires every increasing uses of the
finite resources of the planet,
but that's by no means self evident even
though the Scuttlebutt,
let's say,
especially among the environmentalist
oriented types who might have some
sympathy for,
by the way,
especially with regards to ocean
depletion.
Um,
there's a huge argument and there has
been for many years between the
economists and the biologists and this
is a really important thing to know and
the economists point out that human
ingenuity is such that we're continually
able to make more with less.
And certainly over the last well,
500 years,
especially in the last 150 years.
That's just absolutely evident.
You know,
like people say we're going to run out
of energy.
And I think that's absolutely
preposterous.
It's like it's just crazy as thinking
we're going to run out of mattered.
I mean,
we're going through a bit of a
bottleneck right now because you know
the population is going to increase to
about 9 billion and then it's gonna
decrease.
That's,
that's the most reliable projections and
$9 million isn't a lot more than we have
now and you know,
there's gonna be some environmental
disruption as a consequence of that,
but I don't think there's any reason to
assume that all that capitalism
necessarily requires every increasing
uses of the finite resources of the
planet.
It's also not obvious to what degree the
resources of the planet are actually
finite because we continually think up
new uses for things that nobody thought
had any use at all.
And so it depends to some degree on
whether or not you're willing to bet on
human imaginativeness or you're going to
be a male.
A pessimist.
And I'm not saying that there are
reasons for both.
I'm just saying that it is by no means
self evident that things are getting
worse.
You know,
like I can give you an example.
So,
you know,
in the last,
in the last 15 years,
the millennium goal for the UN was to
have world poverty like absolute
poverty,
so that's less than a dollar 50 a day by
50 percent within 15 years and that was
actually reached ahead of schedule and
we've lived in hundreds of millions of
people into the middle class over the
last 30 years.
And so there is an increasing inequality
in the west because the working class
taken the brunt of that say that
redistribution to third world countries.
But by the same token,
you know,
there's no starvation in the world
anymore except really for reasons of
misdistribution and,
and,
and political purpose.
And people are becoming richer and more
educated all the time.
And we are waking up to our planet to
your responsibilities.
Once people stopped starving to death
and having to burn like dirt and,
and eat,
you know,
substandard food that they've scraped
out at the Brown.
They do start to turn their attention to
things that might be more aesthetic.
And so look,
I don't think there's any reason to be
pessimistic.
Not Fundamentally.
And I guess the reason that capitalism
is compatible with my definition of
good,
I wouldn't say that exactly.
I would say that I don't see an
alternative that has manifested itself
that doesn't have far more negative
consequences.
You know,
it's sort of a minimal pessimism issue.
It's like,
well this is the best devil that we have
and I do believe it is because the
successful societies,
by any stretch of the imagination,
by virtually any metric are the
capitalist societies.
Certainly the case,
for example,
that the Soviet Union demolished far
more of its natural resources.
Too Far less productive consequence than
the west did hearsay evidence.
There's suggestions that between 10 and
15 percent of the total area of the
Soviet Union has been rendered more or
less permanently uninhabitable.
So the question is compared to what?
All right guys,
it's late
and by the answered lots of questions,
it's 10:20.
So a
Jordan,
hope you're doing well.
Says I am.
Who Am glad to see you live?
I'm glad to see me alive too.
That's a good thing.
And hopefully that will continue.
So,
uh,
anyways guys,
thank you very much for attending to
this.
Once again,
I'm,
I'm always gratified by the response to
these q and a's.
It's fun to see what your questions are,
man.
They're,
they'd been really,
they were really difficult tonight.
Then I'm very impressed.
I mean some of them I was afraid to
answer and so if you didn't get your
question answered and it was up near the
top of the vote last,
then part of the reason I didn't answer
it is because I was actually afraid I
wouldn't be able to generate something
intelligent enough on the fly.
So anyways,
like I said,
thanks very much and uh,
I'm going to start the biblical lectures
again in October and I've got some other
videos to release if I can get myself
organized to,
to edit them and put them up and uh,
we'll see you in a month.
So thanks.
Thanks very much.
Good night.